K
N O MAK TSAK SENSEINOWHO CAN.
WEEND"NDOST O T WILLIEND
IN PODCA.
AN AINEY EARHARD CHOSTF
OX &RIENDS."
TOGHT.O MH FOR JNINGE
WILL YOUAVE BEE OUT FRO ON
OTHEAKE SSEOR M
I'M PPED T MAK THA ME
SENSE?
AMAZINGIECEF GDOU
FOD T PY ASIDEO
ITROBABLYUMS UPHAT AINEY
IT'SHILD ABUSE S IWOE TN NONSEN,
I CLD ABUSE.
TER O YEARSE KW TRESISATION, DEF
LENING ANDNCREING RK OF
ICIDE.
SOCIYHOAKES I MOS A
ADD NOP O THA LRENCD TO
SACRICED OUR CLDRE TO TNO
ALR OIRE AINS.
ICAGS UON WHONOWSHA
EY WT?
DON KW WT THEY WT.
MONE POW.
L I KNO I THEO NOT WAN
AT I BEST FOR OURHIREN.
>> Lawree: U A SO RHT.
NSLE YOU SPE PTFOUR
TIMEOING OUT THERE TALNG
THAREN.
AND THEWAED T GET BAC TSCOL.
WE WEROMID I W GIVHE
TEACRS FST PRIORY WN ICOS THEOVF
WE GEHEM TSONEYOEDO
TH CLAROOMS SOHEYAN HAV
GRTENLATI SYSM THEY
WOULD RETN.
USEDT F C A OTHOCIAY
AsleyTHAT MAK EVEONE
SO ANG.
MN,AWREE,HEYOT
30 BLIONOR FM T
AMICANESCUE PN TEOPEN
SCHOS.
EY G THEONEY
FORWO YRS. EXPERIEEDHIS
PATITS A FSTRAD.
EN WE GUT T HE A
COERSATIONITH PARENTSND
FFERT CNTIE LIK LDOUN
COTYTHEY FURIO.
ME O THEMHILDN WH
EMIONA ISSS.
AND EY D'T KNOWOW TO TEACH
TH A HOM
YEARND A HAL ORVEN A YR
BEG AT HOM BACKTOME
VIUAY, N IN ELASSROOM
FRO OF TEAERS THAT ARE
TRAID T TEA THE KID
INABOU THEITTLE ONES,HE
SS O LRNIN
TH ARERYIN TO LEA T
TH AREEARI MKS AHEY
CAN' SEE THE TEACHER MOUTH
AT'SNE THI.I'M NE I WAVEO WR T
MAS IN OER T GETACKN
SCOLS.
I C LIV WITHAT I JT WAN
AND TO YR PNT,OU ARE
ABLUTE RIG.
S TOWERLASS IT I THE
MINOTY CLDREN TT ARE
RELYFFECTEDY TSECAU
MA OF THEON'TAVE THE
TOOL TOO VTUALLY A HOME.
GENEL WAS SING YESRDAYSOHY A TY?
ERE E T PORITS?
GUESSHO I SFERSECAUSE O
THISOU CHIREN.
YOLISTEDLL TSE CITSITH
T.
SO CIFORNIA  USI TT
AND THE LT GOES O AND ON.AT MAS,
I WT MHND SENCESOOL.
I NT RDING
IANTOMTERSAUGH TO M
DA.
THEOAD, TNE CAN TAL ABORESONEYEN
TEACHI EQUY A A O THA
BELIEVELL CHILDRE A EQU
INHE EYE OFOD.
TH GDENULE TAUT AND
WANT MH A SCICE.
I WT ALOF THATAUGH T M
DAHTER
WENLYAVE TM 1 YEARS
BEFO WEEND THE OO
COLLE.
AT'SOT AOT O TIMEHEN
YOUONSIRACATNS A
SUER MTHS WHETHEYREOT
LEARNG ATLL.
>>awree: ECT RIG.
LEAED FM COVIDHA A L
TO WORAOT OF TM FCEDO GOACK
TEACRS UONS DON'TAVE TO
WORKND TY STILLET PD.
>>ill:HAT'S RHT.
DO Y KNO WHAT TSS,
LAENCE
IT A WK SPPAG
IT AORKTOPPE.
'S ATRIKE UNDER TUISE O
MOTE LRNINTRHFUL WHAIT ISS ISCHT
TH HAVEBAONED O
ILDR.
EY HEBANDONED IGAIN
AL SCICE A DA.
U A AINEY WT THROU
LWAUE, VIRGIA, DLANT,DONEYO C T,
L.A. D.C.
DO IT STRE Y IS THE SAM
VOTED T GO REMOTOR ATEAST
SOMEERIO OF TIME?ITEEMSHATHENLYO
TEAC IS HOWUR CLDREN SHODTS AILO
TU INT RIST BECSE I
SEMAICHINGIELIEVE INQUITY.
I DOT BIEVEN EITY.
EQUI IS AROJAN HSE THROUGH
ICHHEYMPLEMENTARXI
IS COMN HAN GOACISMQUITY
Will: NSLE IT'A SMA.ID
RE'SHYT I IORTA.
MAICAL PEOE CONFU THE
TW A GUI MANYEOELONG
I WL SAY TS INHE E,
WREN.
E "N YK TES"HETHER
THEY ADMITD T HOW B IT'SBE.
I D'T KW IF YOUAWHE
ARCLE HOW BADT'S BNOR
OUR CLDRE SHU DOW TOO
TTLE TOOATE, AT IS POI
POLITICIS, T PDITS, THE
ACCOTABITYROMEACHS
IONSNDEDIAYO CANNO PUNH CHIREN A
T AY WH IT.
>> Lree: NSLE I WILL
VE YOU TINAL WLD I THAT
TWEED OUTHEYIDN'TNOW.
AREOU KIDNGE?
DI YOU NOT S THEIDS?
Ainey: YOUNOW, LRENC
I NT TO KW W THIAS
ALWED TO BE USE F CRT
THISAS SPOSE TOE USE F
MASK FORHATEVERT IO GET
OURIDSACKN T CLARO.
NOT C.
OFUBLI HEAH.MA OFHOSE IUES, CRTE
AR SIN AREUBLIC HEAH
ISES.
LTIME TRE A HH
SCNCE. HIG SCHLS IATH OT
T TH ARE PROBLY LEAING
OUR CHIREN AUFFENG.F CRT
>>awrence:OU A EXALY
Will: C I AWER THA
ICY GE OINTN THA
AINSLEY,'M SE Y BOTH SAW
EEWS, WITN THEAST WKTH GOVNOR OT
PUBLICEALT CRISHERE A
BA INTUTNG MEYACKN
Lawrenc THAIS T NSTDARDEVYTHI H
TO GETHATHEYANT.
IF W ARE SPID EUGH TO FAL
R IT,HAME ON US.
BU T KID DESERVE BET